House of the Dragon episode 8 is set six
years after the previous episode so
there are now new actors playing
rhaenyra's kids Jace Luke and Joff and
daemon's kids Baylor and Rayna and
Alison's kids aegon Helena and amond
Alison's family have been ruling in
King's Landing while rhaenyra and her
family have been living on Dragonstone
and rhaenys and Baylor are on driftmark
but now as king viserys and Lord Corliss
both seem near death their families come
together and try to make peace before
it's too late so what happens and what
does it mean this video has no spoilers
for hot day past episode 8. rainey's
Targaryen has been ruling driftmark the
valerion island because her husband Lord
Corliss valerion has been at War on the
stepstones fighting the triarchy Daemon
killed the triarchy's leader the crab
feeder years ago but this war continues
and now Corliss is wounded and it seems
that he might die in the books Corliss
isn't wounded he just gets sick because
he's old callus is now 76 years old in
the books so callus's brother vemond
asks who will be the next Lord of
driftmark if Corliss dies call us wants
lucerus valerion to inherit driftmark
because Luke is supposedly the son of
lane or valerion but vemon says that
since Luke is actually Harwin Strong's
bastard vemond should get driftmark
instead while rhaenys previously said
that she wants her granddaughter Baylor
to inherit driftmark so this begins a
power struggle between Luke vaymond and
Baylor to control the second most
powerful house in Westeros on
Dragonstone Daemon and rhaenyra now have
two sons named aegon and viserys Daemon
has settled in to married life and just
as iris's hobby was his model City
daemon's hobby is collecting dragon eggs
Daemon climbs around the dragon mod a
volcanic Mountain on Dragonstone and he
finds some dragon eggs laid by
rhaenyra's Dragon Cyrax the eggs are
laid in a sack that's hard on the
outside and warm on the inside it looks
like the eggs in the movie Alien and
apparently this is how dragon eggs
incubate in the wild Daemon takes the
eggs to put in a warming chamber maybe
he'll give them to his new Sons dragons
are weapons and Daemon is stockpiling
eggs for future conflict daemon's Dragon
keepers have blood and burns on their
faces it looks like wrangling dragons is
a dangerous job rhaenyra's eldest son
Jace practices speaking Valyrian he says
that aegon the Conqueror ordered for
some trees to be felt cause when aegon
landed on Westeros he cleared away
Forest to build build what would
eventually become the city of King's
Landing he didn't cut down every tree
though there's still that weirwood tree
in the red keep sacred to the old gods
Jace is the heir to the throne after
rhaenyra so he studies hard and takes
his responsibilities seriously unlike
Allison's eldest son aegon who takes
nothing seriously except for
masturbation we see the painted table a
map of Westeros that aegon made before
his Conquest Stannis and Daenerys use
this same table later in Game of Thrones
rhaenyra and Daemon learned that vemond
wants to take driftmark if Luke is
disinherited for being a bastard that
could weaken Jace and rhaenyra's claims
to the throne and if Luke doesn't get
driftmark their family won't get the
valerion's wealth and their powerful
ships so rhaenyra and her family go back
to King's Landing to defend their power
rhaenyra doesn't get a big official
welcome to the cape
Otto specifically keeps it low-key to
undermine rhaenyra and to make her seem
less important it's kind of like viserys
is welcome to driftmark previously
rhaenyra is greeted only by Lord Alan
Caswell we saw him previously
congratulating rhaenyra after her
childbirth house Caswell have a centaur
for a Sigil and they rule bitter bridge
in the reach rhaenyra and Daemon find
that the red keep has changed while they
were gone Allison and Otto have taken
down Targaryen heraldry and covered up
those Dragon orgy murals and replaced
them with symbols of the fate of the
seven the showrunners say that Alison
turns to religion to redeem herself
after she attacked rhaenyra last episode
but this is also a political move
because the faith is closely tied to the
power of house Hightower the faith is
based in the Hightower city of Old Town
these religious symbols May imply apply
a disapproval of rhaenyra's incestuous
marriage with Daemon and of her bastard
children the removal of Targaryen
imagery shows that the targaryens aren't
in charge here
Otto and Alison Hightower control the
throne rhaenyra and Daemon go to visit
viserys and they see that viserys's
model city is now covered in cobwebs
there's even a rat on it viserys is so
sick that he's no longer working on his
passion project and the neglected dirty
City suggests that viserys's kingdom is
corrupt his realm is disordered the
smoke amidst the city evokes the smoking
ruin of valyria after its downfall
viserys's sickness is something like
leprosy he's in constant pain body parts
are falling off and part of his face is
now gone Daemon has always looked to
viserys for approval and love so he's so
devastated to see his brother dying that
Daemon can hardly look at viserys
rhaenyra shows viserys his new grandsons
aegon and viserys baby viserys is named
after King viserys and aegon is named
after aegon the Conqueror of course
Alison already has a son named aegon the
books say that rhaenyra named her kid
aegon the same name to insult Alison and
it also shows rhaenyra's political
Ambitions naming her kids after King
viserys and King aegon suggests that
rhaenyra's children are the true Royal
bloodline unlike Jace Luke and Joff who
are obviously harwin's bastards because
of their dark hair aegon and viserys
have Targaryen blonde hair they look
like true Kings and rhaenyra is now
pregnant again with her sixth child
viserys is happy to meet his new
grandkids though the grandkids are less
happy to meet him when viserys is
overwhelmed with pain he drinks milk of
the poppy which is basically opium a
painkiller so viserys is drugged out of
his mind half the time and lets Alison
and Otto run the kingdom for him so
rhaenyra and Daemon think viserys will
be no help with the drift Mark
succession issue Alison and Otto run a
small council meeting dealing with such
thrilling issues as the taxation of wool
viserys once said that Daemon could
never be king because he'd find the
actual work of government to be boring
if he had to sit at a table every day
putting up with this kind of [ __ ]
Daemon would go mad but Alison and Otto
have the patience and are doing the work
though they're also scheming for their
own Ambitions Alison speaks with a
kingsguard called Eric Cargill Eric has
a twin brother called Eric who's also a
kingsguard and Alison can't tell Eric
and Eric apart also on the kingsguard is
Commander Harold westerling Kristen Cole
Stefan darklin and two other others who
we haven't met yet Alison learns that
her son Prince aegon raped a servant
called Diana Diana is traumatized and
terrified that she'll be punished in
this world we see many women punished or
killed for having sex with the wrong
person even if they didn't choose to a
noble girl who has sex outside wedlock
might be hastily married someplace or
sent away to be a sister of the faith
but lobon girls like Diana may be
considered permanently tarnished labeled
as [ __ ] or Sinners Alison Comforts
Diana maybe she relates to Diana because
Alison experienced viserys having sex
with her when she didn't want to but
Alison also subtly threatens Diana and
pays her so that she won't tell anyone
that aegon raped her Alison presents her
family as the religious and virtuous
Royals so she doesn't want rumors of
aegon's crimes shaming her family nanji
doesn't want rumors of potential Royal
bastards who might become rival
claimants for the throne so on one level
Alison supports Diana but at the same
time Alison silences Diana and protects
aegon's reputation rhaenyra previously
said that Alison wears a cloak of
righteousness Like Her Image as a
righteous virtuous woman is a fake
disguise to hide her family's corruption
Alison participates in enforcing the
same patriarchal system that had trapped
her Alison gives Diana Moon tea to
prevent pregnancy like when rhaenyra had
Moon tea Mela said that Moon tea can be
unpleasant if brewed improperly in the
books Lysa Tully almost dies from
drinking Moon tea so hopefully Diana's
okay Alison confronts aegon and shouts
at him for raping Diana Alice and seems
more concerned about the political
consequences of the rape than about its
Imam morality Alison slaps aegon as she
did last episode Alison's parenting of
aegon involves a lot of shouting and
hitting and this has not made aegon a
better person Alison is disgusted by him
and tells aegon you're no son of mine
Tywin says the same thing to Tyrion in
Game of Thrones and we see in Tyrion the
pain that is caused by a parent's
rejection aegon doesn't get much love
from his father viserys either maybe
aegon's feelings of rejection fuel his
cruel Behavior expressing His Pain by
hurting others like Tyrion in the later
books Alison hugs Helena who is aegon's
sister and wife aegon and Elena now have
two young children who we haven't seen
yet and Alison feels terrible for Helena
being married to this useless cheating
rapist even though the hightower's
political Ambitions are probably why
aegon and Helena got married in the
first place Alison faces rhaenyra and
Daemon after long years apart we see the
scar on rhaenyra's arm where Allison
slashed her last episode the two sides
remain prickly and passive aggressive
with each other rhaenyra says that
Allison and Otto are deliberately
keeping viserys weak and drugged so that
they can rule in viserys's name but
Alison argues that viserys needs the
drugs for his pain and that the
hightowers are just doing the right
thing Jace and Luke visit the training
yard they remember one time when Luke
tried to use Kristen's Morning Star and
almost hid himself in the head Kristen's
actor says that he was more worried
about hitting himself in the balls which
was quote not cool and not rock and roll
Luke is uncomfortable being here to
claim driftmark knowing that he's not
really lane or valerion's son and that
he looks like his real father Harwin
this young man is forced to lie about
his identity for the sake of his parents
politics Jace supports his brother by
saying it doesn't matter what other
people think which sounds nice but it's
really not true politics is all about
what people think and if No One Believes
In Luke's legitimacy he won't survive as
a ruler we see amond Targaryen training
with Kristen Cole the books say that
with Kristen's training amond became a
proficient and dangerous swordsman
despite the loss of his eye Kristen says
that amond will win tournaments with his
skill but aemon says he doesn't care
about Tonys amond only cares about real
fights real killing then he looks at
Jace and Luke Luke cut out aemon's eye
last episode and aemond wants revenge
vemond valerion marches in surrounded by
valerion and Hightower heraldry vemond
knows that in politics what other people
think is everything so he presents
himself self as the true valerion Heir
with house hightower's support
Otto and Alison meet with veymont and
Otto says there may be War soon he means
that the triarchy on the stepstones
could become a threat to Westeros but he
also thinks that there could be war
between rhaenyra and aegon for the
throne which is largely Otto's fault for
pushing aegon as heir to prepare for war
the hightowers want the support of house
valarion so vemon says that if they help
him inherit driftmark vemond will
support the high Towers once they
disinherit Luke Otto hopes to disinherit
Jace and rhaenyra and to put his
grandson aegon on the throne but Alison
has doubts she's not sure if she wants
to go against Corliss and viserys's
wishes and does she really want her
terrible son aegon to be king while the
high Towers make an alliance with vemond
rhaenyra tries to Ally with rhaenys
Rainey is happy to see her granddaughter
Raina who has been living on Dragonstone
with rhaenyra and Daemon but rhaenys is
cold to rhaenyra she's always been a bit
hostile terrain era maybe envious that
rhaenyra is heir to the throne when
rhaenys herself was rejected from the
throne but now rhaenys is really mad
because she believes that rhaenyra
killed her son lanor and apparently
rhaenyra has just let rhaenys believe
that for the last six years rhaenys
wears black clothes as though she is
still mourning the deaths of her
children rhaenyra now says that she
didn't kill Lenor but she doesn't reveal
that Lenor is in fact alive somewhere in
the East she wants to respect Leno's
choice to be free and Anonymous and
rhaenyra proposes an alliance if rhaenys
supports Luke's claim to driftmark then
Luke will marry Reyna and Jace will
marry Baylor so when Jace becomes king
of Westeros Baylor will be Queen and
when Luke becomes Lord of driftmark
Rayna will be the lady of driftmark this
Alliance would make rhaenys's
granddaughters two of the most powerful
women in Westeros but rhaenys has said
before that she's more interested in
keeping her family safe than in getting
political power if the hightowers bring
down Rainier rainis doesn't want to go
down with her so rhaenys rejects
Rainier's offer and says she'll stand
alone we hear thunder in the background
which evokes the storm of War that's
coming and reminds us that ranganese's
mother was Jocelyn Baratheon of Storm's
end the castle that withstands the storm
so rhaenyra feels alone and Afraid
without allies she can't protect her
family rhaenyra visits viserys and asks
him to defend her viserys had told
rhaenyra about the prophecy of aegon the
Conqueror that the targaryens must be
United to save the world from the white
walkers but by making rhaenyra his Heir
then allowing Allison and Otto to take
power viserys has divided and weakened
his family he's failing as a king and as
a father in the morning we see how
viserys's sickness has ravaged his body
we see the pain he's in but today
viserys refuses to drink the milk of the
poppy drug he wants his mind clear so
that he can finally fix the political
divide in his family in the books
viserys doesn't have this terrible
leprosy disease viserys just has a weak
heart because he's fat and drinks too
much and cuts his hand on the Iron
Throne the books say that viserys is
just not that interested in politics but
in the show viserys has good intentions
He does care he just makes bad mistakes
and eventually gets too sick and weak
the author of the books George Martin
says that the viserys in Hot D is a much
better and more tragic character than
the viserys in the books so much so the
George feels tempted to rewrite his
books
Otto holds Court as hand of the king to
decide who will get driftmark after
Corliss of course Otto has already
agreed to give driftmark to Vermont so
this is all just empty political theater
a cloak of righteousness vamon speaks of
the history of house valarion how they
are one of the only surviving families
from old valyria how they've been allies
of the targaryens for centuries vemon
says that he has True valerion Blood
implying that Luke is a bastard and not
a real valerion before Otto can give
driftmark to Vermont King viserys
unexpectedly turns up he walks slowly
and painfully to the throne making this
huge effort to support his daughter
rhaenyra and her family viserys's
brother Daemon helps him to his throne
and puts his crown back on his head when
it falls off it wasn't in the script for
viserys's Crown to fall off that just
happened accidentally and the actors
went with it it's a touching moment of
love and support Between Brothers with a
rough history in episode 1 it was hinted
that Daemon might kill viserys to take
his crown but even after all the fights
and Exiles Daemon is loyal to his
brother viseris says that the whole
valerion succession question is already
settled Lord call us wants Luke to
inherit driftmark and rhaenys agrees
earlier rhaenys had said that she
wouldn't support Luke but now she does
and she agrees to Rainier his proposal
to marry Luke to Raynor and Jace to
Baylor it's a pretty good compromise
really because Rayna and Luke's children
will have valerion blood through
rainer's mother Lana so if vemond really
just cares about the valerion bloodline
he should be okay with Luke and Rayna
taking driftmark but vemond wants the
power for himself viserys calls vemond a
second son which reminds us that vemond
may feel frustrated that he's always
been less powerful than his big brother
Lord Corliss and vemond is angry about
the lies that everyone's pretending that
Luke is lenor's son when he's really
harwin's bastard so vemond finally
shouts the truth that rhaenyra's sons
are bastards and he calls rhaenyra a
[ __ ] vemond knows he'll be punished for
this vamon's actor said that vemond
falls on his sword to tell the truth
suddenly Daemon kills vemond by slicing
through his head the cut is so clean
because Daemon uses his Valyrian steel
sword Dark sister and Valyrian steel is
super sharp in the books vemon's death
is different rhaenyra orders Daemon to
kill vemont and then rhaenyra feeds
vemon's corpse to her Dragon so rhaenyra
seems more villainous in the books here
vamon's corpse is reassembled by the
silent sisters the silent sisters are an
order of women in the faith of the seven
who prepare the dead for the grave they
wear gray and swear vows of Chastity and
silence they're called death's
handmaidens or the stranger's wives
because the stranger is the god of death
in the faith the sisters cover their
face because it's ill Fortune to look on
the face of death but rhaenys watches as
the sisters prepare the corpse of her
brother-in-law she says the stranger has
visited her more times than she can
count her daughter Elena died her son
Lenor seemingly died and now her husband
Carlos might die and if this conflict
between rhaenyra and Alison gets worse
many more people will die by siding with
rhaenyra rhaenys has put herself and her
grandkids in danger the royal family
have dinner and the showrunners took
inspiration here from the Last Supper
painting by Da Vinci rhaenyra and Alison
sit apart from each other which
contrasts with how close they were in
the past this shot is based on an
illustration in the book Fire and Blood
viserys holds this dinner to try and
reunite his family before he dies in The
Throne Room viserys used his strength as
a king but now viserys shows his
vulnerability as a father and a husband
he takes off his mask to show his
withered face and urges his family to
make peace for his sake as a dying old
man and who loves them rhaenyra is moved
by her father's words so rhaenyra thanks
Alison for loving and supporting viserys
all these years Alison finds common
ground with rhaenyra as a mother and
says rhaenyra will be a good Queen and
that startles Otto because his whole
plan is to make aegon King instead of
rhaenyra but Alison and rhaenyra really
try to reconcile so for a moment it
seems like peace is possible but
rhaenyra and Alison's children continue
their conflict aegon insults Jace and he
is betrothed Baylor and Helena Whispers
another cryptic prediction she says
beware the Beast beneath the boards this
evokes dangerous hidden forces of the
red keep spies and rats and secret
tunnels and metaphorically the Beast
beneath the boards could be the conflict
and resentment that still lurks beneath
this appearance of P case Helena gives a
speech about how her marriage with aegon
isn't so bad because aegon mostly
ignores her which is pretty dark but
it's also the longest coherent speech
we've seen from Helena so Otto is proud
of his granddaughter it turns out that
even Otto is capable of being nice
sometimes Jace dances with Elena and
their goofy Joy is probably the most
wholesome moment of all season remember
that rhaenyra proposed for Jace to marry
Elena so this is a Bittersweet vision of
what could have been if that marriage
happened though at the same time Jace
dancing with Helena might be a subtle
dig at Helena's husband aegon as revenge
for aegon insulting Baylor that's more
how it seems in the book anyway but the
adults get along and have a good time
and for a moment it seems like there
might be peace between rhaenyra and
Alison's families so viserys goes to bed
believing that he's done the right thing
and that everything's gonna be okay and
then everything goes wrong a servant
puts a roast Pig in front of amond and
Luke laughs because previously Luke gave
amond a pig to bully him so amond is
furious and he gives a subtly insulting
speech he says Jace and Luke are strong
boys which sounds like a compliment but
really he's saying that they are Harwin
Strong's bastard Sons so the boys fight
until Daemon ends the scuffle with one
finger Daemon stares down aemond and he
wins the staring contest because he has
twice as many eyes it looks like amond
and Daemon would love to fight or make
out or something aemon seems to both
idolize Daemon and see him as a rival
when Daemon killed weymond amond looked
inspired rhaenyra and Alison hold hands
and try to be friends again again but
these mothers have passed their conflict
down to their children and the children
have not let go of the Rivalry the book
says that just as the sins of the
fathers are visited on the sons the sins
of the mothers are as well can rhaenyra
and Allison undo the damage of their
past conflict we see mazaria meet with
Talia mazario was daemon's lover and has
now become a spymaster Talia is Alison's
maid in the red cape and it seems that
Talia is now spying for mazaria so what
is mazaria up to previously mazaria
aspired for Otto is mazaria still
working for Otto or is she maybe working
for Laris now ah mazaria's child spies
listening from the secret passages in
the red keep and that's how larus knows
things or is mazaria working for herself
maybe she wants revenge on Daemon for
him abandoning her visa Paris is dying
he's in pain he's heavily drugged so he
speaks to Alison but viserys thinks that
he's speaking to rhaenyra he tries to
continue his earlier conversation with
rhaenyra about aegon's dream the
prophecy that the targaryens must unite
to save Westeros Allison doesn't know
about this prophecy but she hears
viserys say aegon and you must do this
so Alison thinks that viserys wants her
to make their son aegon king that's not
what viserys means viserys Bailey
remembers that his son aegon exists what
viserys actually means is that rhaenyra
is the prince that was promised the
rhaenyra is the savior who will unite
the realm and defeat the White Walkers
and we know that's not true the white
walkers don't actually turn up until 170
years later in Game of Thrones but this
is a classic Targaryen mistake several
generations of targaryens have believed
that they will be the heroes to save the
world but have been wrong rhaegar
Targaryen believes himself to be the
prince that was promised but then he
changes his mind and says that his son
is the savior aemon Targaryen on his
deathbed says that Daenerys is the
prince that was promised aegon the
Conqueror who started this prophecy
thought that he would be the one to beat
the white walkers at least according to
the showrunner of Hot D that detail
isn't in the books but this is one of
the dangers of Prophecy people assume
that they or their children are the most
important people in the world and that
often leads to disaster Alison now
wrongly believes that viserys's dying
wish is for aegon to be king even though
Alison just said she supports rhaenyra
and just told aegon that he's not her
son but maybe on some level Alison wants
to believe that her son will be king
because Alison and Otto have spent years
building political strength for their
family and Alison's resentment of
rhaenyra for her lies and infidelity
have not gone away so a dangerous mix of
emotion ambition prophecy and confusion
is swirling through Allison's mind when
it's time to decide who gets the throne
who will Alison choose
Alison leaves and the King dies Alone
viserys says no more and my love his
love is Emma his first wife viserys's
actor says viserys never stops loving
Emma and sees Emma as he dies the phrase
no more might refer to Emma saying that
she won't birth any more children
viserys's insistence on impregnating
Emma despite the health risks got Emma
killed and viserys still feels guilty
about that no more might also mean that
viserys will feel no more pain he has
suffered so much but now that he thinks
everything will be fine maybe viserys
welcomes death in a way he's been dead
ever since Emma died
this whole first season of House of the
Dragon has basically just been backstory
this is the prologue the setup the
building of tension before the main
event now that king viserys is dead and
now that we know all these characters
and their relationships the real
conflict can begin
if you want to know the full story of
Hot D you've got to check out the book
Fire and Blood there's also the main
series of books and the world book and
dunk and egg you can get any one of
these on audiobook for free right now at
audible.com ASX sign up for a Premium
Plus trial membership and you get an
audiobook to keep even if you cancel the
trial you can get any Game of Thrones
book or Lord of the Rings or Dune
membership also includes unlimited
access to thousands of audiobooks and
shows in the audible plus catalog sign
up at audible.com ASX or text ASX to
500-500 thanks for watching please like
And subscribe we're doing a live stream
each Sunday night right after hot day
then one of these explained videos later
in the week thank you to the patrons
including Hayden Ross Evelyn Eng Jake
Rellis Jeff Tobin Orden landoy Solly
Emma Stillman and Nick telecast cheers